but first Theresa May was back in
Brussels this week to try and negotiate
a solution to the Irish backstop issue
just hours earlier three of her own MPs
had announced they were leaving the
party because of brexit among other
things and in their joint resignation
letter and a Subaru Sarah Williston and
Heidi Allen said we no longer feel we
can remain in the party of a government
whose policies and priorities are so
firmly in the grip of the ERG and the
DUP brexit has redefined the
conservative party well joining us now
is the former leader of the Conservative
Party and the prominent Brett Souter in
Duncan Smith thank you very much for
being with me what is your reaction to
the fact that three concept of MPs quit
a party this week well I'm sorry they've
chosen to go I'm a little puzzled as to
why they've gone when I've looked at
what they've actually said clearly
Europe is at the heart of it
Europe is a big issue the brexit issue
they all of them didn't want to leave
and I think they've been very strongly
in favor of staying so I can understand
that they feel like they want to make a
statement but I'm very sad to see them
go I saw that Alice will be busy
defending the government's position on
its spending review and on what the
Labour Party called the austerity
program so there's clearly not quite
this complete agreement across them
about what they stand for but you know I
hope the door should be open I hope
they'll come back feel certain that they
will at some point you think they will
eventually reach on conceptive well I
think so because well I hope so because
the Conservative Party is actually a
broad church we've always had competing
views and differences about policy you
know even in government and outside of
government but we've always clung
together always in the best interest of
the nation always put forward the things
that are really important security and
that sense that we always represent the
UK across the board regardless of income
and regardless of status and that I
think it's still the case today and I
nobody could have represented that more
than the Prime Minister frankly you see
you say that and the concept of parties
abroad church but clearly these women
are feeling that that church is
shrinking that the concept of party is
moving further to the right that they're
a dominant voice that is in the
conception party in perhaps the European
research group who are effectively
taking over the party I mean do you have
any sympathy with that point of view
well I just don't agree with it I'm
afraid I said listen to the Chairman
earlier on and I think he's absolutely
right I think the truth is that it
the case of us lurching one side or the
other British people voted to leave a
majority voted to leave the European
Union the Conservative Party is trying
to deliver that now there are elements
which we may agree or disagree about but
we're trying to find a way through to do
that I think from the standpoint where
some of them stand and others they just
simply don't want to leave that's fine
if you hold that opinion that's a
different idea altogether but the Prime
Minister has said we must deliver on the
biggest democratic vote in our history
and I think that's right we're leaving
we're leaving on the 29th and she's been
very clear about that so I don't see any
lurches what I see is a party in
government without a majority feeling
its way forward to try and get to that
point and I'm optimistic I believe we
will reach an agreement let's have a
look specifically at something one of
those MPs said this is Heidi Alan she
said that welfare was one of the big
reasons for her wanting to leave the
Conservative Party I can no longer
represent a party that can't open its
eyes to suffering in our society
suffering that has deepened when it was
in our power to fix it I mean that's a
pretty powerful statement it is but it's
an incorrect statement I have to tell
you this government both the Cameron
government and this government have done
more to help people out of poverty what
we've actually seen is as the chairman
said earlier on more people back and
work than ever before more people having
the pride of an income which allows them
to rise out of poverty this the only one
way really to get yourself completely
out of poverty is through work and we
have seen the highest numbers in work
the highest the biggest fall in youth
unemployment and unemployment that's
been across the whole of Europe we lead
the way in this and also the reforms
that we put forward have actually
benefited people dramatically there of
course is a political round a debate
about this now and I myself resigned
because there were some cuts to it which
I didn't agree with that's the point
isn't because there are some who argue
that actually universal credit while
some people may have benefited an awful
lot of people too many people have been
made poorer because of it have faced
delays to receiving the payment so I
just wonder if this is one of the things
that well know she's a big supporter of
universal credit let's be very clear she
has spoken again and again a defender
you hold on a universal credit no what
actually happened was the last
government took out nearly 5 billion
from it we've now camp
is this government that's put the money
back and that is now allowing the
present Secretary of State for the VAR
Commonwealth and pensions to actually
make the changes to take it back to
where it was this is a massive
improvement you know Universal Credit
has the lowest number of complaints of
any benefit ever implemented by any
government you know things you don't
ever hear that actually the vast vast
majority are actually in a much better
state it's more flexible it means they
don't have to make repeat claims yes of
course there will always be problems on
the fringes you roll it out but the idea
is this is being rolled out to change
those where necessary so I don't agree
with her because she herself probably
doesn't agree with what she's actually
said okay and and then just before we
move on to Bret say I'm just interested
in what you think about the tone of the
political debate in a minute I mean
we've heard anonymous briefings from
some of your conservative colleagues
using very violent imagery towards the
Prime Minister the women who've left the
Conservative Party have themselves seen
a lot of abuse on social media I mean
teasing that everyone needs to dial it
down a bit I wish I think by the way
that social media Twitter is an abusive
process I don't go on it because I think
it's highly abusive it's particularly
abusive to women but it's abusive to men
as well
there's been a heightened sense of anger
after the vote I always thought that it
divides the country a referendum you can
only have one in a generation on
something as big as this people do need
to take a pace back and recognize that
there was a vote there was a majority
now we need to get on with it but
there's no excuse whatsoever for this
kind of level of abuse that's team paint
been taking place
we've seen what's been happening in the
Labor Party with anti-semitism that's
unacceptable any kind of abuse of
anybody whether they be male or female
in politics like that is absolutely
outrageous and should be banned and I do
hope as we bring the new regulations
forward we'll find a way to actually
proceed against people who do that and
also the companies that publish this and
I've absolute agreement with those who
say companies that do online work such
as Facebook and Twitter and everything
else need to be responsible for what's
published on their site so the sooner we
get to that the better we may see quite
a lot of this then curtailed okay well
let's talk about Breck so another big
story in the news this week because
we've seen some members of the cabin
saying that if there's no agreement they
would support an extension to article 50
and delay to break sale I mean is this a
breach of collective responsibility well
I read the article and the letter and I
thought that actually it was my general
sense is that you can have rouse behind
closed doors you can argue with the
Prime Minister you can try and get the
Prime Minister and the government to
move in a particular direction
you can even sometimes indicate that and
the media pick that up but I think
what's really difficult is if you then
state that an opposition to the
government that you are part of publicly
I think that becomes an issue the Prime
Minister has made it clear government
policy is not to rule out a no deal
situation because you can't you know we
are due to leave on the 29th and the
Prime Minister made it clear we want a
deal she's got a deal on the table
they're looking for adjustments at the
moment and I'm optimistic they will get
something and I'm very very keen that we
should be able to support them providing
they get those changes that are binding
but you can't do that if then the other
side knows that no matter what you will
leave you you will not leave and
therefore they can throw anything at you
that would be wrong but to do it
publicly I think is a mistake on their
part so if it is a breach of collective
responsibility do you need to resign
from the governor well that's a decision
they have to take and it's for them and
Downing Street I am a backbencher now I
remember when I disagreed with the
government I departed because I just
felt it would be dishonest to disagree
with the government and then go on
taking as it were the Queen's shilling
you if you are in government it's a
privilege it's a privilege not just for
income but it's a privilege because you
willed a certain amount of power and
influence and I think therefore you need
to think very carefully then that
collective responsibility is how
governments down the ages have worked
and it's how this Constitution works and
I do hope that they will reflect on that
because they're doing the Prime Minister
no good at all and they do government no
good at all by becoming quite so
publicly opposed to what is essentially
government policy the Prime Minister is
absolutely right in this that we cannot
take no deal off the table because we
need to make sure that they those in the
you understand that Britain is leaving
on the 29th and then we will get some
kind of move and there's some quite good
news out there because I see that Steve
Barclay has at least got the EU to
a bit to say that they will now look
very specifically at the stuff that we
put forward as the Maltese compromise
myself other levers and remainders came
together to propose this now the he was
beginning to say yes maybe that is the
solution we'll look at that we need to
get that bound in and we you know why
would you undermine your own cabinet
colleague Jeffrey Cox going over to try
and negotiate a backstop to the backstop
and instead of which you tell them don't
worry about that because we will never
leave on a No Deal you know Jeffrey Cox
has to be able to negotiate you all
support him you're talking about being
optimistic about the way the negotiation
headache I mean I have to say I speak to
some came earlier on the program the
deputy prime minister in Ireland and he
was absolutely empathic that there are
going to be no changes to the withdrawal
agreement so I just want to know what do
you need to see to be able to support
the future relationship be enough we've
said that the changes need to be legally
binding we've been very clear about that
so well in the we need to be legally
binding so you know you define that the
backs the way that withdrawal
Greenland's written it itself is legally
binding the other one isn't but you know
let's just see where the government goes
on this in addition it doesn't have to
be in the textile withdrawal it's I I
think it should be in the text because
that's the way you make it legally
binding but we'll see what the
negotiations produce well I would say
the Simon Kony is you have created a
monster at the moment because Ireland
itself is in deep trouble if we leave
without a deal I mean really serious
deep trouble they are now talking about
that there are big questions being asked
in Ireland of course mr. Coe venes going
to come on and say no change but behind
the scenes in the European Union they
know very well that they do not want us
to leave with no deal and the right
thing to do is to make the changes after
all what do we know about the backstop
it's utterly unworkable even the EU
knows they couldn't implement it
tomorrow if they tried because it's got
the most ludicrous border arrangements
for the UK rest of the UK and and Europe
and it would take chaos so so you've got
now an agreement to implement something
which is unemployment able therefore it
has to have changes why not accept that
and do the changes now agree to make
that process of change part of the
agreement there's not a lot to our
by the way because it's common sense
from all sides and common sense is
really what we're after so let's let
those going to do the negotiations
negotiate and I'd say to one or two of
my colleagues in government a good idea
to undermine them while they do that
it's interesting about the undermining
I'm just with my kind of cynical hat on
no I just wonder if we are moving
towards a situation where the choice put
to MPs is a long extension to article 50
or the prime ministers deal I mean that
seems to be what these members of the
cabinet are pushing towards that was
what Ollie Robbins the brexit negotiator
suggested when he was overheard in a
brussels bar do you think that's where
we're going to end up well I don't
actually because the Prime Minister to
be fair to her has been absolutely clear
there must the Tories may in whatever
she said well I trust in the manifesto
it's worth reminding my colleagues they
all stood on a manifesto well they've
stood on a manifesto they said leaving
on the 29th we're not staying the
customs union single market all the rest
of it so they were committed at the time
of the vote and yesterday by the way
that was reinforced I don't know if you
spotted it but the National Convention
which is all of the heads of the of the
voluntary party in the in the
Conservative Party all overwhelmingly
voted not to extend and to leave on the
29th and basically in support of the
Prime Minister so that is a very
powerful point which is those people who
have worked their guts out to get us
here want us to get on and implement
what the prime minister said she wants
so we're not a million miles away from
achieving a deal but the key question is
you need to be able to say to the
European Union we are united in facing
out that you need to make those changes
necessary and that's in the negotiation
you can't negotiate and I don't have any
of them's ever negotiated before but if
you negotiate by saying oh by the way
don't worry whatever we get
it'll be acceptable at the end of the
day and if necessary we can carry on
talking forever you'd look ridiculous
and then negotiate okay thank you very
much being on the show